well you've seen fiestar's Christian
Bale and Amy Adams there because they
NAB nominations in the leading actor and
Supporting Actress category this comes
on the heels of Isis City Golden Globe
nominations we were with the cast
feeling the love at their Hollywood for
me yes lovely we can make this work it
was very exciting wonderful we say oh
yeah about that I like that it was a
well-earned celebration on the red
carpet last night because playing these
real-life political figures meant some
astonishing transformations for this
cast Christian even gained 40 pounds for
his role as former Vice President Dick
Cheney here's a lion's share of the hair
and makeup which as a woman I'm always
happy to see a man have a longer time in
hair and makeup than me are you even
more ruthless than you used to be we sat
next to each other in the makeup chair
there's a lot of prosthetics going on
Christian didn't get to meet the one
time beep before telling his story but
he's pretty sure mr. Cheney's tough
enough to take it I would hear that he
would enjoy dressing his dog up as Lord
of the Sith when he was called Darth
Vader so who knows who knows maybe he'll
have an interesting take a look at it
[Music]